The Secret Service says it's
investigating a suspicious envelope sent
to President Trump who was mailed on
Monday and intercepted before reaching
the White House the FBI is also
investigating letters sent to the
Pentagon that tested positive for the
deadly poison ricin one of them was
addressed to the Secretary of Defense
Jeff Piquet's is outside the FBI
headquarters in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning is one person
behind this or is a group responsible
that's what investigators will now try
to find out meanwhile the Pentagon's
mail delivery Center remains under a
quarantine this morning the letters were
delivered on Pentagon grounds and now
the FBI is analyzing them one was
addressed to defense secretary James
Madison to Chief of Naval Operations
John Richardson in the initial analysis
both letters tested positive for ricin
which can be deadly the letter addressed
to secretary mattis who was currently
out of the country also contained a 5x8
card with handwriting on it the content
has not been made public but obviously
that will be an important clue for
investigators
ricin can cause death within 36 to 72
hours and can only be manufactured
deliberately but bio weapons experts
caution that field tests are
inconclusive and that you have to
conduct a thorough lab test to confirm
that a substance is in fact ricin
another letter by the way was sent to
the campaign office of Texas senator Ted
Cruz that tested negative for a
suspicious substance it's unclear right
now whether all of these incidents are
related but of course the good news is
no one has been injured
bianna that is the good news and as you
mentioned the search for the culprit
continues Jeff thank you